right hi everyone so I'm Jacky Guttman
I'm gonna talk today a little bit about
an approach to data science programming
that we use at Flatiron health to help
us continuously monitor data quality in
our oncology healthcare data and so
specifically data quality of dynamic
longitudinal data and so I'll kind of
quickly introduce myself and the
challenge that we've been addressing in
kind of maintaining very high standards
for data quality in data sets that are
continually being updated refreshed and
redeliver each month and then I'll show
how some approaches to structuring the
data and taking a kind of functional
approach to code development helps us to
mitigate and simplify that challenge
there's plenty of seats like all over so
make yourself comfortable okay so first
a little bit about me I joined Flatiron
health in January after doing data
science in machine learning and a few
different industries including medical
education public school education meal
kit delivery services so now I do the
same thing only but for oncology and
clinical care so just a little bit about
the sort of problems and type of data
that I'm dealing with here
Flatiron Health is a company that
strives to improve lives by learning
from the experience of every cancer
patient so practically speaking that
means a lot of data right including data
on over 2 million cancer patients in the
United States and that data gets updated
on a continual basis and every month we
freeze and deliver that data to partners
and clients and we deliver it with a 30
day recency so meaning that the time
from a patient experience or outcome
being observed in the
chanak health record to the time that
that observation is in the hands of
researchers and industry leaders who can
generate insights from it and is only
one month which is really considered
unparalleled in the world of medical
research and real world evidence so
something that will become very relevant
to the data quality approach that we're
taking here is that our company relies
on close collaboration between technical
staff with expertise in building
managing and testing data pipelines
statistical and methodological experts
who really love to dig into and evaluate
the data and and clinical experts in
oncology who help us to translate what
we're seeing in the data to what that
means in the real world for patients
with cancer and oncology providers that
are being described by the data and so a
little bit about where the data is
coming to us from our data points come
to us from a wide array of sources
including the more than 800 unique sites
of care that use our electronic health
record technology as well as several
academic medical centers which each use
their own electronic health record
software and and they partner with us on
converting that data into outcomes
research so our one of our major data
products are these kind of national
longitudinal data sets of real-world
oncology data which we update and grow
each month so we currently deliver
datasets on 20 distinct cancer types
these datasets have some shared but non
identical data structures and part of
monitoring the quality of our data over
time includes tracking the changes to
our data delivery from this month as
compared to the previous month as
compared to through months prior or six
months prior and really being able to
understand and draw conclusions about
the quality and consistency of the data
for each type of cancer as compared to
other data marts that we've built out
and continue to maintain and
so what does this mean for us what is
the challenge we need a framework for
detecting and monitoring unusual changes
within a cross variables within an
across cancer types within and across
patients when we're looking at and
comparing kind of different snapshots of
our data frozen at distinct points in
time so we're not just looking at
analyzing a single data set but we're
looking at analyzing many different data
sets in tandem and sort of understanding
the quality of each one relative to the
related data sets until we need to be
able to stand up any kind of data
quality framework on an ongoing basis
right so needs to being able to easily
be refreshed and updated throughout the
month so that we can make changes to our
data pipeline as needed and we're doing
this as the number of data elements
within each data set are growing as well
as the number of unique data sets
overall are growing and growing at a
pretty rapid pace so in addition to that
kind of challenge we also really need to
have reliable and readable code that can
be collaboratively developed by
technical and non-technical and clinical
staff all working together to kind of
synthesize the methodological best
practices with the clinical intuition of
our research oncology experts so there's
many different frameworks and tools that
go into this for us but I want to
specifically focus on some of the more
generalizable learnings here that a few
perspective shifts that kind of make
this comparative evaluation of our data
possible and make it possible in a sort
of maintainable and scalable way so in
order to meet this challenge we knew we
would benefit from really codifying
that statistical and domain knowledge
into a library of modular functions
and we felt that these functions should
be testable they should clear an intent
and they should be able to be composed
into higher-level more abstract
processes and building out these
function libraries sort of serves to
both document and kind of enforce what
we on the quantitative sciences team
established as best practices for
working with our data um additionally
for the purposes of maintainability and
fostering collaboration we wanted to be
able to decouple the high level sort of
checks and reasoning represented by the
code from the low level implementation
details to make those checks really more
transparent and interpretable to anybody
looking at the analysis code and finally
we wanted to ensure a flexible approach
that could take reasoning in code
originally developed for working with a
single data set and kind of seamlessly
extend it to analyzing many data sets
simultaneously and without breaking down
when the structure of a new data set
differs a minor but meaningful ways from
historical data or from data derived
from a different cancer type or patient
population so the way we approach this
problem really borrows a lot from the
principles of functional programming and
I think it's pretty easy for discussions
of functional programming to quickly
devolve into computer science jargon but
for our purposes in thinking about data
science and data quality evaluation in
particular the definition really means a
few key things so most importantly
functions lots of functions and kind of
functions as first order citizens that
we can treat has just like any other
variable and pass these functions it has
inputs to other functions so that allows
us to kind of string together these
functions into higher-order functions
that return new functions depending on
the conditions and context of how we're
using them and next that these functions
or chains of functions with very clear
declarative name
kind of give us an additional degree of
separation from the mechanics of the
implementation and to allow us to sort
of abstract out what is being done from
precisely how that process is being
carried out under the hood and then
finally that these functions should
strive for some degree of purity in that
they avoid side effects and dependencies
on variables and states outside of the
world of the function so this gives us a
kind of sense of confidence that no
matter what else is in our environment
no matter what order we run the function
or how many times we call it if we
provide the same input into the function
we're gonna get the same output out of
it so one thing that's a little bit
different about our approach to as your
data quality is as I said we're often
working with many data sets at once
so whether that's this month's data as
compared to the data we froze at the end
of last month or comparing you know the
data from our advance non-small cell
lung cancer data as compared to the data
for metastatic breast cancer or data
around sequences of therapy as compared
to biomarker testing data we're looking
at multiple distinct data sets that may
or may not have similar variables and so
the way do we define quality measures is
often relative to some other data set so
what we find is that working with nested
data structures where we may have a
panda's data frame where one of the
columns is itself made up of other data
frames or one of the columns is itself
made up of connections to a sequel
database it's a sort of useful
simplifying framework that helps
analysts and data scientists on the team
kind of transition from working with
reasoning about a single data set to
reasoning about many data sets at once
secondly as I kind of mentioned before
emphasizing library development rather
than standalone analyses helps us
support not just code reusability but
really creates a data science culture
that promotes visibility of code between
teams that are often siloed and
encourages the development of unit
testing and function documentation a
sort of primary to the code development
process and then finally this functional
approach really empowered was a
different kind of code review so when we
talk about code review we're often
thinking almost exclusively about
software engineers and sometimes data
scientists really checking the
implementation of a particular piece of
code but on our cross-functional teams
we also want to ensure that those who
are closest to the intention of the code
are reviewing whether the approach we
are taking is reasonable so not just
whether it's implemented correctly so
this style of programming can support a
team structure where those with a
significant problem and domain expertise
can kind of undertake a sort of
conceptual code review and those with
considerable technical expertise can
really focus on an implementation code
review so here's a little example of how
these nested data structures I spoke
about might work in practice so we can
build out a data frame that refers to
several firsts and snapshots of data
taken at different points in time from
different database schemas and tables
and possibly of different disease types
in this case and because data frames are
the sort of fundamental structure that
we're used to working with this kind of
comes naturally to us and we can now
treat individual data sets as we would
individual observations within a data
frame and kind of hold databases of many
data sets with their associated metadata
as just any typical data set that we
want to you understand and analyze so
this kind of allows us to take a kind of
simple function that we have developed
as a data scientist to take in as input
a single data set and output a single
evaluation metric
and create from that a sort of set of
higher-order functions that return sort
of composite evaluation metrics and look
at kind of changes in the quality and
those evaluation metrics over time or
between data sets and we can do this
kind of rather seamlessly across many
dimensions and many data sets because
this is all stored within this kind of
parent data frame so for example here
for we might take a very sort of broad
and generic function that executes a
query against our database and we might
use the kind of notion of partial
functions to sort of fill in some of the
arguments to that function to make it do
something a little bit more specific
right so rather than just execute any
query we create a more specific version
of that that execute the query against
the database that counts all unique
patients in a data set or execute a
query against the database to return a
list of all of the patients in that data
set meaning a specific inclusion
criteria and we can apply that function
to all the nested data sets within our
parent data frame the same way we might
apply a function to all rows of a
particular data frame and and again you
know each data set might have tens or
hundreds of thousands of observations
but the total number of data sets is
probably in the dozens at most right and
so we're not really particularly worried
about kind of vectorization here right
we're talking about something
higher-level that takes in as input an
entire data set rather than a single
observation or set of observations so
starting from this structure we can sort
of begin to add complexity by chaining
some of the functions together into
larger data pipelines or we can build
you in a kind of error handling to these
component functions but the functions
themselves really remain pretty easy to
develop for
data scientists because each function is
still at its core usually taking in
either a single data set or perhaps a
pair of data sets to be compared so I'll
go through some more kind of concrete
examples of what this approach to
programming for data quality gets us but
we found the benefits can really be kind
of broken down along these five
dimensions so first and foremost
readability right this approach really
lends itself to readable code higher
level abstractions that emphasize
declarative intent over procedural
instructions are more easily understood
and sanity checked by our non-technical
staff so that supports the kind of
differentiated code review we spoke
about earlier it's really clear to kind
of look at this and see what it's doing
even if we're not sure about the actual
details of the implementation so this
also provides a kind of self documenting
code where the function and variable
names themselves really describe what is
being done and the actual process of
function design then becomes a process
where the implementation is aligned with
the intention and the intention should
be rather clear from the function names
so
compositionality so another advantage
that we see here is compositionality
which allows us to really string
together simpler functions into
higher-level functions of increasing
complexity without compromising the
flexibility readability or testability
of the component code so in this kind of
example if we're working with pandas
dataframes as inputs we can use the pipe
function to compose functions into a
larger pipeline of transformations or
operations and then we can kind of save
that pipeline as its own new function in
order to apply it consistently over
multiple data sets and we can generalize
that to functions that don't just take
pandas dataframes as inputs but any kind
of arbitrary Python function so either
by creating our own sort of composed
function as we see here with the help of
a thunk folk tools that reduce or kind
of using the built-in compose or compose
less functions in the tools library we
can take we can take a sequence of
operations like what we might see on the
left where we're flying okay
sorted and then add previous and then
reversed and then to list but it really
needs to be read from kind of inside out
and bottom-up and it's really
counterintuitive to how we would
normally read language and we can kind
of reverse that into a new and
appropriately named function where the
function definition of that new
composite function can itself be read
from left to right or top down in a more
intuitively interpretable way and and
perhaps there's even just a clearer way
to refer to that new composite function
so again this concept of
compositionality really supports the
readability concept as well
okay so next another important advantage
we see here is reproducibility so we
want to really have confidence that for
any analysis running the same function
with the same input should always
produce the same result so by developing
functions where we avoid mutability
we're calling the function changes the
actual state or value variables defined
outside of the function and preventing
other similar kinds of side effects we
can really avoid hard to test for bugs
and we don't want so this the success or
failure of our unit test to depend on
things outside of the actual function
and its input so so this this concept of
immutable inputs and outputs and
processes that you know are
deterministic and always return the same
result when given the same inputs that's
going to help increase the sort of
reproducibility of our code and then
closely related to this as I kind of
alluded to is this idea of robustness so
modular functional code that avoids this
kind of mutability and side-effects and
external dependencies it's going to be
easier to test and if we're using unit
testing more effectively we're gonna be
building more robust code in the long
run so code that is harder to test just
won't get tested or won't get tested
effectively and so it will be more prone
to unexpected errors but that's
unexpected errors what about expected
errors the functional approach can
actually help us here too by wrapping
sort of unsafe brittle functions with no
exception handling wrapping them in
their own sort of try catch exception
handlers where the new exception handled
version of the function gets returned as
a
you newly-named more robust function and
that robust function can then be sort of
mindlessly deployed in an analysis
without breaking the functional flow of
the code or requiring the analyst to
think deeply about potential exceptions
that might occur each time they're using
the function so again the tools library
here provides us with the excepts
wrapper to turn any coloboma into sort
of a more robust version that has its
own bottom value avoiding kind of the
side-effect of throwing an exception if
an exception is hit and then finally
efficiency so this is kind of last on
our list of benefits because for this
particular use case again we're often
much less concerned about games and
efficiency and especially if that's
going to come at the cost of things like
readability reliability and robustness
it's not something we're typically
optimizing for but even so there are
ways to take advantage of lazy
evaluation and caching of previously
computed values in a way that provides
us with improvements and efficiency as
well so here for example we can use a
lazy MapReduce paradigm to iterate over
chunks of records returned from a
database in this particular case which
are pulled just in time from the
database in order to apply some
arbitrarily complex composite function
to each chunk and again when we're sort
of building out and developing the
function we might just use the generator
to just give us one chunk at a time and
make sure that the function is working
as expected and
so we can again lazily sort of return
each chunk compute the aggregate result
and then use the map and concat
functions from the tools library to to
power much of this kind of lazy
evaluation so this is like really just a
sort of simple MapReduce type example
you probably would just do the whole
thing in sequel but if you had a more
sort of complex function you could use
this sort of paradigm to do it in a
similar sort of MapReduce style that
would be lazily evaluated and caching so
additionally if we expected that over
the course of an analysis a function
could be potentially called several
times with the same inputs and that
function execution was itself kind of
expensive
we might save some computation by
caching or memorizing the results in
hashable dictionary using the func tools
LRU cache decorator so we'll have this
hashable dictionary we'll hit it up on
all subsequent function calls and only
newly compute the results if it can't be
found in the cache so since we've
designed our functions in such a way
that we know they should always return
the same input I mean the same output if
they're given the same input we can
avoid the kind of duplication of effort
of recomputing results for common inputs
and we can decide based on our use case
how many recently returned results it
makes sense to store in memory so that's
the kind of efficiency game
and then yeah that's it you can find out
more information about what we do at
Flatiron and what kind of data products
we build on our blog and yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah yes yeah yeah so a few different
things so one is that we'll use certain
for things that are always changing
between many different data sets right
we'll try to specify certain
characteristics of the data in
configuration files but usually for
things like where we okay add a certain
column at a certain point in time to a
data set and then from then on that data
set has that column but prior to that
date it didn't have that column again
will often wrap up a lot of these
function calls in these sort of
exception handled versions of the
functions so that you know if we're
hitting up for if we're hitting up let's
say a disease that didn't exist prior to
you know March or if we're hitting up a
variable that didn't exist prior to some
other date we can just sort of return
n/a and there's no particular comparison
to be made often what we're doing is
sort of like comparing over the history
of the existence of a particular
variable or the history of the existence
of a particular data set how has that
data set changed how has that variable
distribution change but we don't want
the functions to be sort of brittle and
just error out completely if that
function to me if that variable didn't
yeah yeah
very photogenic for actual
[Music]
yeah yeah that's a great question so we
definitely have very sort of
cross-functional teams usually reviewing
most of our QA reports and these these
alerts can sort of be filtered up
appropriately and so I think you know
usually the first kind of level of
checking is sort of done at people with
people who are really familiar with the
data model and sort of like oh we know
we just like change the instructions
that we gave to the people curating this
particular variable and so if we're
seeing a change maybe it's because of
these new instructions that we issued
starting last month and you know if
there's something that's not necessarily
immediately apparent at the kind of data
model level like okay we started like
coding this particular derived variable
differently then then we then like
filter that up to people with more both
like clinical and like pharmaceutical
understanding so people who might know
okay there's a new change in the sort of
like market history of a particular drug
approval or there's a change in
something in terms of the disease or
testing that's being done that could
explain and so I think we really try to
have people at kind of all functions in
our company involved in sort of being
able to find a kind of underlying reason
for that change
[Music]
yeah I would say that sometimes we are
reacting to them but there are certain
kind of quality issues that they're
really not apparent on the sort of month
to month basis so these are like most
critical checks we do are comparing this
month for last month and sort of making
sure like did we just stop getting
documents from this particular provider
and into this variable is always missing
from you know this particular source and
and those are the kind of like highest
priority sort of checks but there's a
lot of more subtle changes that when
we're sort of like reviewing things on a
month-to-month basis it's not really
apparent that anything unusual has gone
on but when we start looking at things
like maybe this month as compared to six
months ago or something there might be
changes that start to emerge and so
those might be things that depending on
the severity of them don't necessarily
need to be like immediately alerted to
our clients or it doesn't necessarily
mean that we need to interfere with the
sort of delivery of the data but
ultimately like something needs to be
sort of better understood and addressed
yeah yeah
I'm not interested in your if there's
any extra friction in your hoarding
problem
a lot of people starting the program and
there's a lot of data scientist or
yeah so this is an interesting question
and at there's fine I will admit that
actually most of my team programs and
our and so we are for the most part at
this point developing these libraries of
functions in our and I think it's a
little bit more common to accept this or
a functional programming paradigm coming
from a language of R and so maybe that
is one of the reasons that kind of helps
you know allay the friction right so
that kind of our untidy verse
evangelists have already sort of made
this view kind of very prevalent in the
our world more so than in the Python
world but yeah I think that you know
there does tend to be a lot of
differences between code that is
developed between our sort of
quantitative sciences teams versus the
data insight engineers that work with
and the software engineers that we work
with and and and they Mont might not
accept this same sort of paradigm but I
think again for for our particular
team's purposes you know because there
is such a huge variety of technical
skill and technical background you know
we have people coming really from an
epidemiology and biostatistics experts
but certainly not coming in with any
previous computer science terminology or
kind of best practices and so they may
be a little bit more of a blank slate
versus others that are coming from more
industry data science roles that may be
used to doing things a certain way their
previous companies so we do have rather
long onboarding process and kind of are
very standard about this is the style of
code that we like to endorse and we give
them a sort of long time to adjust and
transition to that but yeah I will admit
that's a luxury
anything yeah
you
[Applause]